-Well, it's the end of the week,
and that's usually when I catch
up with some personal stuff.
You know, I check my in-box,
return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
And I was running a bit behind,
so I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out
some thank-you notes right now,
if that's cool with you guys.
James, can I get some
thank-you-note-writing
music, please?
[ Soft piano playing ]
Oh.
Thank you, Kamala Harris,
for being
half-Jamaican and half-Indian,
whereas Mike Pence
is just half-and-half.
[ Soft piano playing ]
Thank you, Joe Biden,
for always looking like
you just came from
a "Top Gun" audition
you think you totally nailed.
Nailed it.
[ Soft piano playing ]
Thank you, Women for Trump bus,
for looking like
an optional accessory
you can buy
for Alt-Right Blogger Barbie.
[ Soft piano playing ]
Thank you, Shark Week in 2020,
for somehow managing
to make TV shows about
deadly shark attacks
feel like a relaxing escape.
[ Soft piano playing ]
Thank you, study that found
McDonald's packaging
contains toxic chemicals
or, as their hamburgers
put it, "Twinsies!"
[ Soft piano playing ]
Thank you, beluga whale being
rescued this week,
for looking like your
drunk friend at the party
who needed help
getting his jacket on.
[ Laughs ]
There you have it.
Those are my thank-you notes.